so i go and i see this vanity fair did
this video of nicole kidman
eating bugs let's take a look at some of
it so we can talk about it shall we
here she is that's nicole
i'm nicole kidman and i am going to eat
four courses
of bugs
[Music]
i am here to reveal my hidden talent
eating micro livestock corn worms
they're still alive
[Music]
mm-hmm you see what's going on here it's
like fear factor only with nicole kidman
it's fantastic in a way
very moist chewy comments on what's
humanity fair but i need a little water
okay so let's pause it's all fun and
games hahaha
how much do you think nicole kidman got
paid to do that you think she did it for
free
do you
do you remember when we talked about the
kardashians and the fake me
kim was just like holding that like
beyond burger and everyone was like you
didn't even bite it
she got a lot of heat for that remember
khloe kardashian all half naked with
travis and they're like daring it's
synthetic meat it's really healthy and
you and i sat on this show and we read
the ingredients it's not healthy it's
junk
now you've got nicole kidman eating bugs
so what's going on here
there's always something going on so you
know there's somebody else who likes the
idea of eating bugs
bill gates
shocking
the washington times let's take a look
it's called let them eat bugs
interesting
gates is a guy who sparked headlines
like this from the post in february bill
gates wants you to eat artificial meat
he likes the fake meat too by the way
guys oh yeah and this from
survivingtomorrow.org in march
billionaire elites want you to eat bugs
and you will
hmm
this the article cites from the world
economic forum in september of 2019
burgers bugs and the shift to a new way
of eating
oh so that's interesting there's all
these high-level celebrities it's bill
gates
the world economic forum and they're all
coming out
it's pure coincidence of course with the
same message eat fake meat and eat bugs
wow that's a
head scratcher going on here
i read further in the article some
interesting little tidbits
gates
the associated press wrote in june is
considered the largest private owner of
farmland
in this country with some 269 000 acres
across dozens of states according to
last year's edition of the land report
100. well that's interesting to me
hmm
turn to the second page of the article
bill gates rich nation should shift
entirely to synthetic beef
and from his own gates notes post a few
months earlier in december 2020 he wrote
there's another global disaster we also
need to try to prevent climate change so
in the name of climate change they're
talking about synthetic meat they're
talking about eating bugs there's
another little line buried in this
article though
you ready
all things bugs another u.s startup
raised a hundred thousand dollars in
initial seed funding from the bill and
melinda gates foundation to develop an
eco-friendly
ready-to-use therapeutic food product
made from insects
for children in famine-stricken
countries so interesting okay there's a
lot of pieces here
i don't have the answers on all this but
there's a lot of floating pieces right
you got bill gates buying up a bunch of
fun what's he going to do with the
farmland
i mean he's not going to use it all to
grow this bug mixture that he's then
going to sell and make a [ __ ] ton of
cash off of right
i don't think so
or i mean he's not going to buy up all
that land and suddenly there's all these
food shortages and
then people need to eat the bugs that
wouldn't happen no that doesn't that
can't be it's a lot going on here
i get nervous whenever there seems to be
an organized message like that so here's
what i'm going to say to you
here's what i'm going to say to you
eating meat i was i was i was a
plant-based for many years
eating good quality meat is very healthy
for you
okay and by that i mean grass-fed
grass-finished meat i mean
pasture-raised meat you ever been to a
farm you know how these farmers take
great care
this wild seafood this stuff is really
hard to duplicate
in when you eat a plant-based diet
i know haters are going to hate but i
did it i did the plant-based i did the
nuts and seeds i did the beans i did it
healthy i didn't eat daring garbage meat
i didn't help it was very hard to
replicate
the nutrient density of these items
these meats are very very high and
they're very potent for the body and
they're very very good for you in many
many ways okay
we're gonna have some health experts on
that talk about those diets and why
people struggle who sometimes remove
these whole food groups
so what do you think happens to a
society
where you remove these things you think
they get sicker
or better it just seems to me like a lot
is going on in the world right now
that's making people sicker
chronic illness on the rise gates can't
decide whether he wants to prioritize
you eating bugs and synthetic garbage
meat or getting another booster shot
that's interesting an interesting focus
on health and wellness no
huh
so what i'm telling you is to get armed
with information
okay
i find it really odd i'm not a
conspiracy theorist i'm really not
people who know my work will know
sometimes i haven't been conspiracy
theorists enough for some people's taste
but bottom line is you got a lot of
strange fires going on at food plants
you got a lot of shortages popping up
you got a lot of people in positions of
power that seem to have a coordinated
message now about eating bugs and eating
synthetic meat and how meat is bad and
in order to save the climate you've got
to go plant-based and you have a
chronically sick population
okay that's getting worse
people who are chronically sick also
always remember people who are
chronically sick typically become
repeat customers for big pharma
because you get hopeless right you don't
know what to do you're like i feel sick
let me go you get another prescription
all of a sudden you're on a prescription
that rotates every month all of a sudden
you're getting x amount of tests that's
prescribed they make a fortune off sick
people the big pharma industry makes
all of their money off of the sick you
get yourself well all of a sudden
they're in trouble i'm just saying
there's some something going on here
that stinks
i don't know what it is i don't know
exactly what gates intends to do with
all that farmland i don't know what i do
know is that the messaging putting out
there being put out there about food is
bad for you so i'm gonna tell you do
your own research
you get one body i'm gonna say it again
i'm gonna say it over and over again you
get one body in this life take care of
it ask your questions do your research
make your decisions
if you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here